hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you dude dude hey guess
what what I I am [ __ ] on it this year
when it comes to Christmas
hey Christmas go [ __ ] yourself that's
what I'm saying
I'm talking all kinds of [ __ ] I'm
backing up I'm wagging my [ __ ] head
at your Christmas I'm sorry I'm just
excited I got all my [ __ ] wrapped and I
shipped it out today [ __ ] you over over
that's it all I need to do is get a pair
of Jordans right whatever the [ __ ] virzi
says it and that's it it's over the
greatest [ __ ] feeling ever
this holiday is like you know when you
become an adult it's dreadful it's like
ah [ __ ] man I got a you know I got to
bring the kid over here I gotta [ __ ]
get this person something off Jesus what
do I gotta get this guy a calendar or
something I got a show I got to show him
how much I care about his stories that
have no [ __ ] point you know got at
least get him a stocking stuffer for how
many minutes to have my life did he
waste this year just the the [ __ ]
stress of that I got to tell you
something buying the things and wrapping
them slapping the name on them and and
then once you mail that [ __ ] thing
I'm it's like a high if you like runners
talk about like runner's high you know
which is hilarious because if you look
at the look on their face when they're
running it does not look like they're
enjoying themselves every person I've
ever seen jogging down the street like
not everyone but most of them they look
like they should have quit like two
miles ago they leaned into one side they
kind of got that [ __ ] stroke mouth
going you know what the [ __ ] one it's
like two just enough already enough we
get it we get it we get it your your
your your fitness [ __ ] guru guru slow
down walk go over that taco stand all
right get yourself a [ __ ] taco or
something all right
just relax
who do you hate more joggers of bike
riders yeah who do you hate more joggers
of bike riders neither I like everybody
I'm the positive force that balances out
your life get the hell out of my office
[Music]
hey you crushed on the podcast let's see
if you got another one in you don't hit
me you going to the gym what for were
you all Hollywood you're trying to get
your abs going for 2018
beefcake all right
why geez is the anti-climatic then you
got to come back come on give me a kiss
goodbye Let me kiss goodbye actually
know what give it to me when I come when
you come home all right I'll see [ __ ]
gross oh I got all the tags Nia for the
gifts and stuff yeah and I try to make
your nia when I said from Uncle Bill and
Antonia I try to make it look like your
handwriting but it clearly looks like
mine
plus I'm left-handed so it's smudged
across and I forgot to sign your name to
the card the one that said how much we
care about him it's the second time I've
done that there's gonna be a hostel I
didn't do that to you you me I'm kidding
come back please
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] that women are into
is just but you know that's she got a
card inside my name - what about you
know all right I mean everybody's gonna
think I don't care no they're not they
have lives
anyways I got this [ __ ] [ __ ] wrapped
I got I got like one more thing to get
my laughs and I may have all of that
[ __ ] wrapped all right and I just see
here you go
all right here you go leave me alone and
then I'm gonna I got of like eloquently
come off the wagon I'm still on the
wagon I got 15 weeks in all right I'm
already a third of the year in 26 weeks
is half a year but that takes me into
February and I'm going to the Rose Bowl
so that that's the next tough one that's
the next hurdle I have to get past is if
I can somehow go to the Rose Bowl and
not get off
which I've done before I've done it I
think I've done a couple times I've done
the Rose Bowl sober I don't know what
but I'm actually I was thinking the
other night like when I come back to
drinking all right when we rekindle our
relationship you know like you ever see
there was a particular person out here
in Hollywood had an abusive relationship
this guy was beating the [ __ ] out of her
and stuff and then she went back to him
you know being like no he fixed it this
time and I remember the talk-show hosts
were like going like are you sure you
know what you're doing this is me going
back to booze with my little barbed wire
tattoo I think I'm just gonna go
straight to heroin like I for some
reason feel like I can handle it at my
age you know cuz I know how stupid it is
to do I would just do it like one time
and just be sitting there like and right
in the living room - just don't don't
have this shame that most junkies have
you just sit down with your family and
just say listen this is something that I
want to try I'm just gonna do it once
and I would appreciate it if you guys
would hang out during my entire hi and
make sure that I don't tip over and bust
my head open on the coffee table with
Eva now we have the kid proof things
around it to be actually a lot of that
kid proof [ __ ] becomes junkie proof
after a while you know I'm kidding
and I'm not making light of the
nationwide hair or an epidemic but we
all know that the nationwide heroin
epidemic is not the biggest story in the
country right now that's not the biggest
story it's not that they've poisoned our
food supply fellow Americans it's not
that it's not that after all the
protests they're still gonna put that
[ __ ] pipeline in it's not that what
is the biggest story huh Matt Lauer
buying a [ __ ] dildo for the stand in
whether person it's not having a
president who's out of his [ __ ] nights
not that the biggest story in the United
States of America right now is Eli
Manning is being sat on Sunday and his
210 game streak is coming to a close
in all of New York shut down they
couldn't believe that Alicia Manning I
didn't know his name was Alicia I have
never seen such a [ __ ] ridiculous
reaction while ignoring real [ __ ]
problems there's like 30,000 [ __ ]
tornadoes or whatever the [ __ ] we had
hurricanes
I have [ __ ] all that Miami's give me on
the water like the [ __ ] text that I
got from New York sports fans
my friends like the level that they were
having a [ __ ] meltdown you know [ __ ]
the rope-a-dope that's going on in the
Middle East right now where you got a
[ __ ] band of [ __ ] 3,500 nitwits
bankrupting a billion-dollar company is
they got a bag of rocks or what flying
f-18s at him blowing all our cash [ __ ]
all of that Eli Manning is being sat on
Sunday I got a buddy money he flipped
out so bad he's actually betting against
the Giants it's like dude if Geno sucks
which I don't think he's going to no one
knows how good Geno Smith is he played
on the Jets no one knows how good
anybody is when they play for the Jets
there the Jets
sorry everybody out in Queens but you
know there's an element of truth to that
okay the Patriots used to be like that
all right so there is hope for you guys
God knows Bill Belichick is 70 years old
we all saw Tom Brady try to recover that
bad snap last week right you saw when he
was running after that thing he looked
his age he looked like a guy who forgot
to set his parking brake and was
hobbling after his [ __ ] car and then
realized like I'm not gonna break my leg
I don't [ __ ] it I got insurance on this
car and just flopped on the ground
yeah if Geno Smith shits the bed the ELA
is gonna be back in the second quarter
all right and by the way this happens to
every quarterback no matter how good
they were no matter how good of a class
act they were this happens to every what
the [ __ ] happened to Peyton Manning
after all those years of standing there
with at least 19 inches of his 42 inch
neck exposed between his helmet and his
shoulder pads it finally [ __ ] gave
out
and what did that [ __ ] guy Jim Irsay
the [ __ ] National Enquirer of [ __ ]
sports owners he turned his [ __ ] back
on him okay in Peyton Manning he went to
[ __ ] Eastern Europe he went to
Transylvania right and he got [ __ ]
child's blood pumped into his [ __ ]
whatever the hell at virgin blood pumped
into his [ __ ] neck and he comes back
to Jim Irsay and says oh right whatever
that whatever the [ __ ] he talks why
don't you put me in this week whatever
the [ __ ] he said to him you know
probably make more money doing that and
a foot larger right what did Jim Irsay
say he said Peyton with all due respect
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] three feet and
neck we're moving on what tank and the
rest of this season so we can get Andrew
Luck that's what the [ __ ] happened look
what happened to Bret Farah right be
[ __ ] he actually had to go to the
Jets Eli Manning all these guy with his
quiver and bottom lip all he's got to do
is sit on the [ __ ] bench for a couple
of place that's it that's all you got to
do everybody losing their [ __ ] minds
how could they do this how could they do
the exact same [ __ ] thing that they'd
done to everybody you'll remember the
end of Derek Jeter's career when all
those sports writers were [ __ ]
bitching about him saying he's he's
costing the team he's too [ __ ] old
should they move them over to first base
this happens to everybody you know you
don't think they're talking about me
right now
the way I'm [ __ ] looking these days I
have like three friends of mine that are
I love them they're the biggest New York
fans ever and I got like [ __ ] phone
book level texts about what was going
you think it's gonna end pretty with Tom
Brady this guy wants to play the leaves
like 60 at some point oh [ __ ] Bob
Kraft is gonna have to sit down and be
like Tom it's too old I mean look at you
you still have a Beatlemania haircut
what [ __ ] year did you come in the
league
you got a [ __ ] mo Howard haircut what
the [ __ ] part I mean I don't even what
to tell [ __ ] Bill Clinton was still
president when you came in I don't know
what to tell you this happens to
everybody yeah it's obviously a shame
Eli's [ __ ] great I got to tell you it
sucks as a Patriots fan watching the
Giants just [ __ ] dismantle and I
wanted one more crack at him we had
nothing to lose you already kicked our
ass [ __ ] twice we'll come back like
Tex Cobb for a third one and I was
loving and there would always be an
asterisk even if the Giants made the
Superbowl and even if the Patriots made
the Super Bowl this year if they came
back without Tom Coughlin and we won
that one that still would be a that's
still one to be the same that would
that's the level of respect that I have
for [ __ ] the Giants organization Tom
Coughlin and Eli Alicia Manning I'm just
breaking your balls New York fans I know
it sucks you know what it really is all
you guys flipping out and you're acting
like you love Eli Manning but you really
are is you're a bunch of selfish [ __ ]
because watching Eli gets benched it's
just reminding you of how [ __ ] old
you're getting and now we're all gonna
die it reminds you of your own mortality
so rather than deal with that you call
in sports shows losing your [ __ ]
voice you know and meanwhile we're
[ __ ] blowing a billion dollars a
month fighting people who have
slingshots and a bag of dynamite
anyway I swear to God if I was running
this is how I would handle Isis I would
just [ __ ] take I would I would
whoever those [ __ ] gamers are that
case you got to play on the giant TV
screen in Dallas Cowboys Stadium if
you're good enough to do those guys who
had those drone races in in that Stadium
like that would be my defense against
Isis some intelligence and then I have
those [ __ ] sitting in Cowboys Stadium
when the Cowboys didn't have a game and
I just have them flying around you know
blowing up their jungle gyms that I mean
that's how I would handle it okay and
considering I haven't even fist
fiscally researched this on mne level I
haven't talked to anybody who's even
remotely informed about what's going on
over there
the fact that I did this in my own
self-contained think-tank
I cannot even begin to describe to you
how much this makes sense to me you know
come on do it you got you don't sit by
yourself sometimes and just start
solving all the world's problems you
start walking around your house
whispering pretending you're getting
interviewed by Oprah come on we all do
this don't we
Oprah's sitting across from you do you
consider yourself a hero is you sitting
there muttering to yourself and then
somehow you come into your [ __ ]
present you just in this scrub in like a
[ __ ] old rice check off a bowl and
you have that split second have just
really stepping outside of yourself and
being like well I'm really I'm a [ __ ]
crazy person and then all of a sudden
the front door opens and your family
walks in and you go right back into
character and they have no idea could
you stand in there with this phony smile
and I'm wearing his sweater sorry
anyways
Happy Trails Matt Lauer you know you did
a hell of a job waking everybody up for
the last 20 years and you got a little
sideways how do you buy a sex toy for
somebody you work with and then write a
letter I mean Jesus but when I just walk
around with the [ __ ] neon sign around
your goddamn neck I swear to God did
these people get this successful and
they just like wanna sabotage their own
[ __ ] career
Oh although maybe he's just like old
school he came in he came in the league
when that way he won't know when you
could do that because you got to think
when he first started by and like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that if it was the
late 90s when you think about the cell
phone technology texting didn't even
exist it was none of that [ __ ] there was
no Facebook there was nothing I mean
what could that one poor woman do Rick
run off a bunch of copies put them on
telephone poles
it just you know and then you just have
an assistant run out and tear them down
Matt Lauer's screaming from the window I
said right I don't know I don't know
anyways I'm gonna be in New Mexico in
Albuquerque New Mexico southwest part of
the state he's part of the country and
I'm gonna be in Arizona this weekend
come on down I'm here at the route 66
casino where the [ __ ] am I gonna be in
Arizona
I like Arizona dude dude because it's
only an hour away on a Southwest flight
again on the [ __ ] plane I listen to
the stupid jokes then they say we're
beginning our initial descent please
raise all your tray tables and your
seats please
how come this [ __ ] thing isn't
loading why is my signal for work not
Jesus Christ well we'll get back to this
by the way by the way thank you for
everybody who's buying tickets to the
Patrice O'Neal comedy special I'm comedy
benefit sorry I'll be promoting this
right up until February Tuesday February
20th 2018 7:00 p.m. at the city centre
in New York City the sixth annual
Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit benefit
benefit and we keep adding more people
all right we just added the great Jim
Norton Jamie Norton Brendan burns
Pete Cory le Joe DeRosa Sam J Robert
Kelly Jessica Kirsten Sipho sounds and
rich vos and myself we'll be there
honoring the memory of the best stand-up
comedian I ever saw live all right and
where am I going to be in Arizona I'm
gonna be at the desert diamond casino
I'm just a [ __ ] dirtbag this week
aren't I route 66 casino in the desert
diamond casino in Sal route a SATA Rita
Saturday Arizona this is the degenerate
tour and then on December 10th I just
added this date I'm gonna be at the
Eiling tanea tur in Santa Barbara
California all right
Santa Barbara speaking of Oprah Winfrey
one of her giant houses is up there
maybe she'll show up to the show I'm
gonna be up there and then December 14th
I'll be at the Hard Rock live in
Hollywood Florida and December 16 Bob
Carr Theater in Orlando Florida and on
the 15th I'm going to the magic I got to
get some tickets for that by the way I
got to figure out what the [ __ ] I'm
doing over there anyway so I read some
advertising here
what else did oh my ribs are feeling
better in case you were asking in case
you were wondering I got masseuse and
trying to lay off the drums
I'm trying did I mention that I'm
building a drum room finally in my house
I've had it I've had it with having to
drive to go to my [ __ ] drums just
having a kid now you got to wait till
they take a nap and then you run out
there in for [ __ ] 20 minutes to an
hour in six minutes
you play [ __ ] drums but the little
kid monitor there right so you can see
when she gets up then they go back and
that's how I'm going to do it that's
that's my game plan you know what he
actually did I I have almost every
modern drummer from the 1980s and I was
looking at the other day and I saw that
old Steve Jordan one that they didn't
like 86 or 85 where Dave Garibaldi broke
down his ghost notes and all that [ __ ]
for messing with the kid I got to get
that down I got to learn that [ __ ]
that's that's my next [ __ ] goal all
right my goal listen to become a better
person my goal is to recreate what was
already created and then hope that
somebody notices and is impressed by me
all right let's read we got four Reed's
here today can you guys hang in here and
listen to me read out loud for the next
few minutes okay if you think the
[ __ ] I was saying was remotely
amusing this part would be hilarious
we're exposed really my level of
intellect all right
tipsy elves everybody everyone needs an
ugly Christmas sweater this time of year
if you want bragging rights for the most
talked about sweater at your Christmas
parties listen up
talk about your tipsy elves sweater and
other products you saw on the website
I've yet to go on it I don't know
anything about these I know that
hipsters love this [ __ ] hey hipsters
here we go
tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas
sweater designs that are like nothing
you've seen before this is where they
show my I show my age I don't think
Christmas sweaters are ugly I think
they're very festive that it's like
wearing an oriental rug that has like
snowmen on it they're not for the faint
of heart be the life of the party with
hilarious ly irreverent designs all
right let me look this [ __ ] up let's see
what [ __ ] tipsy elves is bring it to
the table here alright they're saying
they're [ __ ] hilarious I sit there
saying I'm remotely amusing and these
[ __ ] have the balls to come on and
start talking all this [ __ ] you know
like they just put out a Chris Rock
level [ __ ] special all right
tipsy elves calm all right let's see
what they got here let's see how Jesus
okay all right these guys are definitely
bringing it what the [ __ ] oh my god they
got an Obama one that says miss me yet
on the back they should have all his
drone attack with a list of all the
people who weren't terrorists can we
[ __ ] be balanced in this country
jesus [ __ ] christ I don't understand
this hero worship of that guy I really
don't what did he do you know what the
best thing about Obama was he could
deliver a [ __ ] speech you know and I
don't even know how good he was
considering he was in between bush and
[ __ ] Trump's so that's really like
you know that's really set in the bar
like low for me once shame thinking yeah
you're not gonna fool me again I mean
how do you not follow that and then I
don't know what this other guys do but
Donald Trump is so [ __ ] bad II I
actually had this thought the other day
well thank God Mike Pence's in there
[Laughter]
okay I got to give it up to these guys
tipsy elves yeah if you want to [ __ ]
up look at sweater these guys are
definitely definitely crushing it I like
this suit though I gotta be honest with
you I am actually diggin the suit
anyways while you're shopping for your
ugly sweater check out their holiday
attire for your
or as a gift like adult onesies oh boy
oh boy isn't that is this is a weird
time to sell adult Dunc onesies huh is
there a picture of the latest guy who
got [ __ ] rousted out of his career
for buying sex toys they even sell wild
and crazy ski suits for your you skiers
out there for men three-piece christmas
suits
thumbs up to those interactive sweaters
are they consensually interactive beer
pong cornhole gross and hilarious
holiday tees for women holiday leggings
oh oh he's got a [ __ ] it up for you
guys
sweater dresses and cozy adult onesies
specific sizing for men and women so
everyone can get the perfect fit right
now my with get 20% off tipsy elves calm
when you use my code burr but you are
are a checkout that's 20% off anything
you order on the site go to tipsy elves
calm enter my code BER at checkout to
get you 20% site wide disk out that's
tipsy elves calm and my code Barbie you
are on oh look who's back
indogene talk about how every man looks
better in a suit you know guys when I
sit on the promenade checking out who's
gonna be my next boyfriend I have to
admit I am I gravitate to a guy's junk
that's in a three-piece suit I don't
know what it is I just feel like he's
gonna be a little more classy can you
can choose from one hundred from
hundreds of top quality fabrics and
customized all the details including
your lapel jacket lining monogrammed and
more in dope cheeto has been featured in
major publications including GQ Forbes
and the fat I think douchebags read GQ
don't they what kind of an [ __ ] has
that kind of [ __ ] time to pick out
like the perfect pen and pencil set
there's what you write out your [ __ ]
you know $64 to The Electric Company
sorry Forbes and Fast Company and are
now the largest made-to-measure menswear
company here's how it works like GQ
magazine is for somebody who [ __ ]
wants to act like they're like an
international spy but isn't one you know
that just kind of [ __ ] old people out
of their pension I'm sorry
anyways visit a showroom or online at
endo Chino calm pick your fabric choose
your customizations and submit your
measurements place your order and wait
for it to arrive in just a few weeks
this week my listeners can get any
premium Indo cheeto suit for just 359
bucks and Indochina calm when entering
bar at checkout that's 50% off the
regular price from made-to-measure
premium suit plus shipping is free
that's Indo Chino calm promo code bar
for any premium suit for just $359 and
free shipping incredible deal for a suit
that will fit you better than anything
off the rack ever could ah look who's
back me on DS me on DS why are we
fighting these douches but doo doo doo
be on these B undies you could oh I did
I [ __ ] pick douche I've been bobbing
lately on this Sun why do I keep doing I
got to pick up easier word to rhyme with
I'm I've been just been off my game
lately you know me on DS me on DS Isis
is on a jungle gym doo doo doo doo me
undies be on DS we could beat them with
a slim jim
why go down that road bill every year
millions of people receive the least
like gift of all time underwear
underwear right even if you get your
wife some sexy underwear that's good
it's kind of a gross gift isn't it I
guess on some level she's psyched you're
still attractive but you know what you
really are saying you know I'm come on
you know what are you saying
you don't I mean I'm surprised feminists
haven't brought that up lingerie is
slavery but we still give it to our
families and our loved ones who just
wanted it's not a weird sentence to just
read out a contest but we still give it
to our families and our loved ones who
just don't want it it's kind of rapey
but maybe it's not that underwear
the problem it's the kind of underwear
let me tell you about me undies me
undies the only underwear that makes for
an amazing gift me undies me undies May
underwear the perfect gift that
everyone's going to love for you
it's a goddamn holiday it's a goddamn
holiday miracle this year don't give me
underwear give me undies this holiday
season to get your exclusive 20% off the
softest underwear and socks you will
ever wear free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
dot-com slash bird that's my undies calm
/ / oh my God look who's back it's MV MT
movement watches the holiday season
dooby dooby doo is [ __ ] in here with
movement watches you can skip the crowds
you know standing behind that woman with
her wide ass so anything worse than a
wide flat ass with no signage on it you
know at least you could do is [ __ ]
you know rent it out right we'll be back
with a scamming you can skip the crowds
and standing in crazy lines and find a
gift they'll love at prices that beat
department stores movement watches start
at just 95 bucks
all right just throw it in a stocking
hand it to the person get on with your
life
put some bourbon in your eggnog you're
done and 95 bucks at a department store
you're looking at 4 to 500 bucks
sorry movement watches are just 95 bucks
at a department store you're looking at
4 to 500 bucks for this kind of a watch
because you can get both we gonna watch
for like 95 bucks but it's like a
[ __ ] Timex Morewood figured out that
by selling online they were able to cut
out the middleman in retail markup
providing the best possible price at
such great prices movement watches make
wonderful holiday gifts to classic
design quality construction and styled
minimalism over 1 million watches sold
in over 160 countries it gets 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to movement watches
calm that's MVM tea calm this watch has
a really clean design that makes a great
fashion statement now it's time to step
up your watch gang go to mV mt watches /
/
join the movement all right okay I think
is that it I think that's like 28
minutes yeah I'm gonna try it you know
something I'm gonna try to get out do
some stand-up tonight I think I'm gonna
do that because I got some gigs the next
couple of nights right go out there
shake the [ __ ] dust off I've been in
the Edit room almost every night of this
week okay only two nights but it felt
like every night with my a dee dee we
are currently editing season 3 of f is
for family I don't know when it's gonna
be as gonna be out later on next year
that's how it works animation is a very
slow process but I'm really loving how
this season is coming together and I'm
hoping you guys are too and if you don't
then I guess we won't get a season four
and if we don't get a season four I will
be sad but I also have a lot of free
time so it's one of those deals so who
knows who knows what happens or maybe
I'll just take the show and just start
[ __ ] putting it up on my website
maybe I'll do something like that that
would be stupid building you have to
finance it yourself and you go bankrupt
just [ __ ] watch season three so I can
stay with my cushy deal at Netflix can
you do that for me if not can you go to
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit I'll
be announcing more special guests as we
go we might have a surprise guest that
night we're reaching out to some people
we'll see what happens it's always a
great night we always tell Patrice
stories we give each other's [ __ ] and
it's obviously for a great cause okay
that's it please enjoy the music as we
transition into a an old-school Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcasts from a thursday from
years gone by er possibly earlier this
year I have no idea that's it have a
wonderful weekend you [ __ ] and I will I
will talk to you on Monday
[Music]
listen little Shane
we break each other's bodies
[Music]
whose each other plane
this YouTube video yeah thank you bill
there we go bill burr was telling us
that he found a fine video clip called
best wrestling promo starring this guy
jumpin Jeff farmer I'm judging I'm
guessing that's it's from like the 80s
and this is before Vince McMahon sewed
everything up so it's an independent
wrestling thing I don't know I don't
know where at but this guy is legit so
basically what it is is this guy jumping
Jeff farmer he's gonna promote Jeff
farmer jumping Jeff farmer he's gonna
promote his big wrestling match coming
up on the Saturday he's gonna do the Ric
Flair thing mean something he's supposed
to be doing that [ __ ] and he it might
have a little bit a little bit of a
tough tough time we've all been spoiled
by the professional nough severe esters
and how they're able to rock the mic and
really get on there and ad-lib and talk
and this guy apparently doesn't have the
skills he's still in the development
phase I'm not gonna judge his entire
career but oh right he got salmon here
he's a wrestling expert Sam is an expert
I mean will really come running down the
hall of those floppy feet you know we
got to promote that Kevin Smith's
calling the show today - oh yeah
show just keeps getting better and
better oh my god he tweeted a while ago
that's he's he's sleeping on his phone
right now so so they wake him up for the
the interview today so Kevin Smith in
about 15-20 minutes all right let's
check this out best wrestling promo ever
let's go now to that interview folks
there's jumpin Jeff farmer Jeff a while
back what a Matthew had with motley yep
[Laughter]
Motley Crue's you turn the tables on me
you turn the tables in the wrong way you
got me mad now I'll sit around I've
listened to everything you had to say I
did everything necessary look when you
turn around and you backstab me one way
or another and you treat me out of
what's rightfully mine that's when I get
angry now I'm
doing the challenging I'm issuing a
challenge to you Motley Crue's get in
the ring with me this time I'm going
full force farmer bad guy is the worst
that is the worst intro ever last week
yep yep Motley Crue's I was supposed to
go on with this [ __ ] he looks like he's
gonna piss himself guys I'm saying he
played the fake sting in one point is
that true Sam really
does it look familiar he never had a
career in wrestling really someone was
trying to say he's in the Wrestling Hall
of Fame the W whatever the whatever that
is he's an IP double you know if I can
get Sam started help till school yes
ma'am I thought you knew everybody I
wrestle you don't know now around David
you know that guy you know another game
what are you doing thing you had to say
Oh
give a listen when you turn around and
you backstab me one way or another and
you creep me out of what's rightfully
mine that's when I get angry now I'm the
one doing the challenging I'm issuing a
challenge to you Motley Crue's get in
the ring with me I'm going full force
jumping Jeff armor-all wrestling promo
bloopers are genius great
Ken Patera some bloopers out there are
you ever see the one where Booker T
calls Hulk Hogan the N word and then
humiliate is fine
coca-cola Tony Atlas uh black boy like
back when he was all thunderlips
this was great when he turns around he
looks at the girl in his genius lex
luger genius a lex luger blooper right
there
the best part is opposed to cover his
face and then he makes it look like he's
rubbing his hands will fly after all so
the whole time he's got his chest is PEC
still moving up and down this one this
one's good because it's taken like when
they do smack down they tape it to
rebroadcast and they edit it sometimes
yeah but if you have a satellite dish
you can pick up the satellite feed and
watch it live her fur so they got the
satellite feed of hulk hogan just
completely like starting over on it yeah
okay something to do with building this
company just makes you sick the fact
that i am the one that put this company
on the map it helps you make it what it
is today that makes you sick to your
stomach brother yeah all those weird
sense that you have all those billions
of dollars the houses that your kids
live in the twenty million dollar
vacation home
[Laughter]
I convinced just by ass that [ __ ]
Vince
let me tell you something I think you're
starting to believe in your own [ __ ]
Hogan I could've had anybody play the
part of Hulk Hogan I can about anybody
bring Holcomb on one second McMahon
you actually think anybody cut around
with Hulkamania look at all the guys you
gave the ball to look at all the guys
that had the belt look at all the guys
the brand of the throw line nobody ran
as hard it as long as I did McMahon
it sounds like a real argument
lastly think if you actually think I was
just the right guy at the right place if
the wrong at the right time uh let me
say it one more time so you completely
understand if you actually think that
was just the right guy guys right place
well then you're a bigger delusional
bastard then I thought you were McMahon
[Applause]
[Laughter]
mania going what I say right now big man
right now we just settled there waiting
for somebody yoke Adam a couple of weeks
ago yeah they're just battling and you
were the one that I wanted to get in the
ring you were the one they really did
mess up didn't they yeah this is good
you better make up with the Lex Luger in
the Ken Patera one dude ya know and next
Lex Luger mr. Luger mr. Luger
I saw what just happened out there with
ron killings I just want to ask you I
mean what are your plans for the next
show Super Bowl Saturday I mean are you
gonna take care of ron killings what
kind of disgusting this spill it's
despicable lack of respect is that Billy
what's his name show look at a match for
the total package Lex Luger super bro
[Laughter]
but his voice is just regular yeah and
I'm gonna make sure that for the
whipping that you gave me
[Music]
someone's really good there's a couple
things coming in botch mania on YouTube
and Shockmaster
seen it before I think shock response
mania is very visual but okay ten laughs
in my life being a top five
shock master this is my favorite one
it's psycho said he doesn't realize he's
alive okay
that perhaps you can't take it how do
you address those skeptics all the
skeptics and all the people have a
little bill they're here at a man of few
words this is the Shockmaster
basically there's the myth they were
supposed to uh they had a mystery
partner and he was supposed to be like
the next big good guy in WCW yeah and he
was supposed to bust through the wall
but nobody told him there was a support
2x4 under like at the base of the wall
yeah so he tripped right over the 2x4
and falls flat on his face the entire
thing is the funniest thing you ever
seen
it's sting and they didn't the British
bulldog a horrendous day was supposed to
big this big pump up of this but when he
fought I'm Tom went when Ric Flair cuz
he's one of the greatest of all time of
dis surrounded by fire
bombs awful and his reaction to what
happens I watched this 700 times and the
shy cry every time to shock master he
was just an old wrestler from the date
of you eat from he was tugboat endo
he said they put a stormtrooper helmet
literally a stormtrooper helmet that
they covered in glitter oh it sparkles
make sure you have the the the sting
lead in Iowa so that you know this was
actually so bad that this guy had a
whole gimmick he was gonna be the next
main event guy they changed his entire
gimmick so that he was just a klutz that
always lost they couldn't do anything
with him after that because of his debut
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
helmets [ __ ] head do you think other
his voice was done by a guy off the said
with a live mic they didn't tape it he
did it live so when he trips you can
hear them now we just watched too bad
British bulldog and sting lawful and Ric
Flair this was like the Rick flash so he
was trying to put this together flash
but when when he fell to the wall Ric
Flair Oh
[Laughter]
the promo way up to the point this is in
front of audience yo yo just a live
audience and it's live on TV this is
their big thing leading up to a
pay-per-view of live television by the
pay-per-view so you can see this guy
they're expecting big things from the
shock completely gonna stay on it a
little further so you could get some
more lead-up good wishes bad promo
[Laughter]
[Music]
because the other guy's gonna do is
promo for em it's not even a regular
supposed to break through I watch this
live in 1993 it's the greatest moment in
pro wrestling history there's never been
a better completely destroyed
not only do you have to be as quiet as
you can because you can hear Ric Flair
say okay then you can hear offset where
he's supposed to getting ready to do his
promo form you can hear them making fun
of him his costume injustice yeah he had
a giant fur vest that was 3/4 length a
giant sparkly helmet and no shirt this
shop mascot was literally after this
show they changed his entire gimmick he
became a construction worker the
constant falls down stroke master keeps
having them okay the rules
okay everybody contain them so I will
try that's like big J
Oh our partner is going to shock the
world because he is none other than
[Applause]
my boy yeah this is a promo
yes his voice hasn't started yet you see
him you see bossing him with his hands
yeah voice didn't start yet talking like
he's talking like it's a mine the worse
is none of them said you fell through
the wall with this guy without laughing
[Music]
[Laughter]
my stomach stapled I keep breaking the
wall is falling audio better I was
trying to nail a fuzzy logo to the wall
how cupcakes are made Elmo falling he's
got down on a sand pail on his head no
stopping him to when he puts the helmet
back on
I love the fact that he's standing he
has to wipe the ground dirt look at
sting his bad all I have to say is he's
calming everybody that here's the moment
all I have to say is our part is gonna
shock was off timing
I gotta say it again please talk yo you
wanna hear the whole outfit everything
mistake yeah he doesn't have a good body
terrible he'll stop I'm sorry you gotta
understand too
this was the Sid Vicious yeah and the
Harlem Heat and they were beating up a
British Bulldog a sting for like months
sir and this is the guy who get down is
going to match the intensity these are
those three guys in the company I would
love to know what is the Shockmaster
thinking after his helmet goes on I just
[Laughter]
see that from behind them someone
tweeted that they made fun of this on
Raw recently yeah oh we get it with the
clips or I get you a clip right here
alright good yes supposedly that they
went real inside and made fun of this
clip on Raw it's a year ago
alright here's one more from the
Shockmaster there's no more there he
just felt this is what he's doing he's
waiting for that guy to start driving
and when he yells he thinks it's his
voice I mean the guy was yelling at he
thinks that it's his boy his backstage
voice guy but it's not it's five seconds
which seems like a million is where
everyone is collecting themselves to
pretend the Shockmaster who everybody
went holy a stormtrooper helmet he got
the Halloween stormtrooper helmet with
to the next Valley got the Captain
Caveman perfect and kept his jeans that
he drove to the arena and I think I
heard a better version from the guy that
just tweeted me peg man I got a 945 I
got to go to the airport you gotta go
bill yeah I got a bird came by to say hi
and we will be back until next week
Thank You mr. burger Barbie keep up the
podcast I'm a big fan build upon this
shot they're all looking at than going
the Shockmaster just self they all see
the whole gig going down the toilet
could you go back could you go to shark
master
Raja's see if it's a better clip master
on raw is the is the Shockmaster on
wrong like that's that's the when they
made fun of him that's not the original
shock master they have a all right he
has a glitter stormtrooper helmet and
why is CID all scared of him cuz he
looked all scared why did he turn around
a douche bag so he just felt through the
[ __ ] world the shock master is a dud
the most terrible person be this brutal
villain this guy from another planet oh
my god jeans and boots and a friendless
voice the first thing you see is him
falling you want to patient me I just
fell through the wall is so funny now
what's the setup on this now is this
from 1904 2009 yeah a year ago they made
for the off see much better on e-bay is
known as promo
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
before I love this guy
I told you it's just so bad
everything about is poorly done
everything oh yeah then one thing I
noticed yeah this is when they and then
rod did a spoof on it a year ago yeah
cuz they were putting out what was the
original Shockmaster for 1993 I saw the
[ __ ] 17 almost 17 years later raw
[ __ ] goof doll let's see how they
goofed all right no but where's that
coming I think it's coming from that
wall
I don't know you know what sounds like
it's coming from right over there today
anyone even get it the wrestling fans
who love the Shockmaster clip yeah yeah
that's great and then there with Dusty
Rhodes who is what it was probably in
the top five like mic guys of all time -
like dusty and flair who is the best was
the rock the best mic guy no not at all
not probably not even he might not even
be the tough fire really he was great
fantastic dusty Ric Flair players better
Roddy Piper my name
I'm trying to figures that was Barack
was good at making catchphrases
how about sergeant no no Oh Jake the
snake isn't in the top of in the top
five probably and you know not the rock
is not in the top five he's in top ten
strong hallways probably better Bobby
that's the five the rock was just good
at making catchphrases and then he's the
best though dusty and flair I'm neck and
neck also sing one they're also saying
Owen Hart had a really good one really
good blooper yeah that damn goddamn
Shockmaster do that
I like gonna be able to laugh until like
I'm actually [ __ ] tears are coming at
my eyes trying hard one funny
I just recently stopped watching it like
yeah but you still watch it with this
thing like wow he's right on his bucket
it's the worst thing that could happen
the worst thing dude right there and and
the helmet falling off and he scrambles
to put it on and it's so clumsy and they
just stand there trying to be tough be
tough with all the glitter on his chest
it's not you
[Music]
because
beauty
two rounds
all right we got Lisa she's very pissed
off Lisa in Jersey Lisa hi Lisa how many
girls says he is he with it just shows
that the product of woman he's with I
just can't believe that women fall for
his crap oh you're an easy mark listen
to you yeah I would get you with within
within two days of knowing me you'll be
subscribing Yeah right just by just by
your answer sweetie I can tell you go
this is classic yeah right whatever
here's what is on your mind I'm a big
arrogant bigmouth [ __ ] [ __ ] right
and you want to curb you want to destroy
that any way you can so here's what you
do if you're pretty this is what pretty
girls [ __ ] up they they try to hear a
giggling this is here's what pretty
girls [ __ ] up they try to get me because
I'm a fat [ __ ] so what they try
to do is they played a love game they
give me something they think is precious
which is [ __ ] that's what girls ought
to give that's that can an attack mode
you whatever plan can you have other
than your [ __ ] on it if you want to
destroy a man's [ __ ] arrogance what
do you do to do that other than use your
[ __ ] hey what's she doing the singing
because she really don't have an answer
it's like what else can you do talk
about [ __ ] the French Riviera with me
lately yes I could innately it mainly
here's what you got to understand ma'am
we don't like you no matter what you
know we don't care if you know all the
quarterbacks in NFL we don't know if you
we don't care if you know every team
color we don't care if you know all the
GM's we don't care if you know every
basketball we don't care because
innately we don't like you so you try to
infiltrate your personalities on us and
you realize that you're not interesting
then you try to [ __ ] us when that
doesn't work you're ours at first and
then look at if I work
hard to get what I want right you agree
with that we work hard to get [ __ ] I do
what I do like like you know grow on you
my girl been around for years
yes she's [ __ ] homeless people off
the street that was a snack for
procuring I'm just talking about like
like a girl that wasn't dinner we would
go out to dinner you and cursed me out
for a little while you would you would
understand because you innately you
don't have your own philosophy cuz
you're not really saying anything now
yeah when Patrice brought up the fact
that the pussy's the weapon when they go
went when you girls go into battle for
the first time this is before any get to
know you get to know you whatever with
it's just because we know that's all you
want in the beginning that's all we want
but in the beginning that's not all I
won unless that's all you got all you
got is [ __ ] why would I try to go down
like that you sound like you know this
is the way I keep her on track and this
is you know yes look at your mouth like
you can tell there's no guidance in your
life because you're too comfortable you
happen about nothing right because I'm a
guy and that's what we do about you but
you miss stuff you talk about that you
think is about some thank you but it's
always interesting when guys talk
alright Lisa thank you
we got a couple more here let's go to
Kevin in Nebraska Kevin jump in find
your spot and go hey man you need to
shut no good soldiers in trouble let's
go right to Colorado Kirsten what's up
hey I totally agree with Patrice I
absolutely agree with the trees women
need to know their place know what they
do do it well and please their men and
their man will be around forever good
girl
Wow ever absolutely men need a rider be
a writer it's not that difficult keep
your mouth shut do what you're told
be who you are is that what you think is
that what you do with your girl let's go
to John and Utah John yeah save my
marriage
I was the doting the doting husband and
was always it was all about her starting
to listen to him and things were going
bad so I started going whoa
Patrice do I started following his
advice what would Patrice and we're
happy a happy man is a happy
relationship a happy woman is a
miserable man she wanted me to be the
man that's what the [ __ ] point is you
got a duo a one-shot deal a relationship
advice show for oh my god like one hour
two hours whatever you want to have it's
just simple we'll work that out of
Washington will get Patricia O'Neill on
the show by himself just taking calls
why about your relationship here's why
you can here's why you should always
understand why it's legitimate I'm a
[ __ ] mess physically like I'm trauma
try to get a shave when these days butt
naked if you look at me naked next to my
girl you were going what the [ __ ] like
my self-esteem has to like when I [ __ ]
I have to go
why is she [ __ ] me I wouldn't
ever give me no [ __ ] and it's like I'm
looking at it going wishy up to this is
like my esteem you gotta be no carry a
motive but I start realizing it's a mind
thing all they want all they want is
just a [ __ ] they can look at
and blink slow and respect and anyway
it's not about beat lemon and it's
subjugate them it's about they look at
you and feel like they don't need to be
your mama that said that they go wow
this [ __ ] is in my corner he
handles his business you know this is
what I'm saying your house situation you
become a million times sexier cuz that's
a match that you did is buy a [ __ ]
mansion that's a mansion
you bought a mansion Anthony so it's
like your girl can't help but go dish
[ __ ] when you're renting she can
kind of that other half of a voice that
tries to put you down she could look at
you and go this [ __ ] is witness 59 you
bought a mansion again clothes she wants
you more you're hotter than you was when
you was written it's a fan [ __ ] Wow
that's really good hey wait a whole lot
of man let's go to John you guys you got
people then reacted oh yeah John in
Pennsylvania Patrice I'm impressed dude
you know how to keep your woman in line
without a contract yeah man it's mine
[ __ ] dude it's mine I'm telling you it's
like it's like it's pimping without
beating I'm making it so [ __ ] it's just
stay want back dude don't ever let them
convince they don't want that what will
they do without like a man's goddess you
ever see a woman at once like they try
to you see how did success to a woman is
do as being like a guy it's like I I do
this I do that I do this and that and
and and we can care less like a sexy man
like [ __ ] a female Opie like a woman
a woman that's in the same position
that's Ovie's in is not any sexier than
the [ __ ] that works at McDonald's if
she's cute
that's the thing
about us we don't point very good point
I'll see a woman while she would calling
you the black dr. Phil that's the name
of your show we're gonna give like one
or two hours so now it goes black dr.
Phil with Patrice O'Neal all right
Don's listening we got to set that up
you want to do uh I don't know when one
would it make sense
sounds like get my [ __ ] whole my
straight like I just go off with it you
know let's just turn on the freaking
Channel and just let the phones ring and
see what happens for an hour yeah well
we'll set that up in the very near
future let's go to journal from wack-bag
turn it off hey guys listen Patrice
you're absolutely right I've been
jumping through hoops ever since I met
my wife trying to get the [ __ ] and once
you got it they put up more hoops for
you to jump through I got to go home and
implement the O'Neal standard in my own
the O'Neal standards Wow she knows
eventually you're gonna figure out if
she doesn't constantly apply pressure
that you're gonna figure out holy [ __ ]
what like my man he was nervous that his
wife was gonna leave him and I go let me
ask you a question like if you really if
we really sit down if my woman left your
woman left your woman you go what would
you really miss about her exactly like
what would you miss it's your own
arrogance our arrogance as men because
their possessions and if they leave it's
like um it's like losing your favorite
pencil but it's like maybe your favorite
pencil doesn't even sound like it's the
number-two pencil
[Music]
[Applause]
peaches
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you